hablemos de las aristas de esta medida
no afecta El crudo exportado por
oleoducto y el precio finalmente se fija
en 60 dólares por qué estas condiciones
y porque bueno la mayor parte de la
Unión
Europea consumen ya no es por oleoducto
sino por vía marítima o hay una
excepción es Hungría porque como no
tiene salida al mar y depende como han
dependido muchos países europeos de los
hidrocarburos gas natural petróleo de
Rusia a través de de oleoductos
gasoductos pues entonces pero es como
una excepción y la intención es bueno
que a partir del cinco de diciembre
incluso tengo entendido que Europa deje
la Unión Europea deje de comprarle
petróleo por mar a Rusia claro Hay unos
límites también con esto creo que la
idea es que se ve se pague el petróleo
ruso un 5% por debajo del precio del
mercado se habla de que el costo de
producción de barril de petróleo en
Rusia es como de 30 a 40 equivalente a
30 40 dólares por de abril Entonces si
se limita se pone un techo al precio del
crudo entre 60 o 70 dólares por el crudo
ruso se considera que ese sería el
equilibrio fiscal O sea que realmente no
habría ganancia para Rusia si se le
pagara eso pero Rusia ya ha dicho que no
va a exportar de entonces petróleo a
Europa al menos por mar Pero Eso suena
todo muy bien hay otra cosa que hay que
tomar en cuenta que Rusia ya ha estado
vendiendo petróleo
contra sanciones
altamar de manera clandestina a otros
petroleros como de la ejemplo Así que
hay este tema y otra cosa que podrían
diversificar si no lo han hecho ya
exportar a bajo precio petróleo por mar
los rusos a países del Tercer mundo que
les convendría comprar más baratos se
reunieron con el líder de la unión
africana acaso habrían estado hablando
de eso y tienes a indochina tienes
Sí perdón es que hemos perdido justo la
conexión cuando comentaba las
exportaciones de Rusia por altamar de
forma clandestina no sé si podría
recuperar un momento esta idea y
precisamente en relación a lo que
apuntaba que Putin dijo que la medida
era irrelevante mientras que se
Consideró que era laxa Sí sí la cuestión
es que ya ha ocurrido desde el comienzo
de la guerra que se imponían las
sanciones sobre el petróleo ruso que
petroleros rusos o petroleros con
petróleo ruso trasbordaban en alta mar
de manera clandestina el petróleo a
otros petroleros como de la India para
ser procesados en refinerías de la India
y después se revendidos creo que a
mercados europeos Así que yo diría que
hay dos cosas que hay que tomar en
cuenta Rusia va a expandir esas
operaciones y de todo países del Tercer
mundo probablemente de África también
Quién sabe si también de Sudamérica y
otra cosa va a fortalecer la labor si no
está ya fortalecida de la inteligencia
rusa el servicio inteligencia exterior
porque probablemente estará coordinando
Estas actividades de trasbordo de
petróleo clandestino o venda venta
clandestina de petróleo al Servicio del
Estado ruso lo cual implicaría que para
occidente tratar de neutralizar o
enterarse lo que está pasando tendría
que aumentar la labor de cooperación y
actividad de inteligencia naval
inteligencia marítima satélite
intercepción de comunicaciones drones
que patrullan y tengan